[Music]
essence here is split into two in such a
way that to begin with two different
ways of considering it are involved in
part essence must contain difference
within itself in part just because of
this the two ways of considering it
merge into one for the abstract moments
of pure being and the negative by which
they are distinguished are then united
in the object so considered the
universal common to both is the
abstraction of a pure inward oscillation
or of pure self thinking this simple
rotatory motion must become more complex
because it is itself only motion by
distinguishing its moments this
distinguishing of the moments leaves
their unmoved unity behind is the empty
husk of pure being which is no longer
actual thought no longer has any life
within it for this process of
differentiation is quad difference all
the content this process however which
places itself outside of that unity is
an alternation an alternation which does
not return into itself of being for
another and of being for self it is
reality in the way that this is an
object for the actual consciousness of
pure insight utility
her graph 579 is a short paragraph and
there's a good bit going on there some
of which is playing off of the important
transition that took place in the the
previous paragraphs not least thinking
about thing good and thought and pure
being and the negative but leading us
towards a important crux where we're
going to reintroduce a concept that we
had brought up before and there's this
you know area and this this portion of
the text that of utility that's what
this paragraph ends with and utility
really is going to be to use the title
of this this entire section the truth of
the Enlightenment we're going to see
that carry forward into the next section
but we'll talk about that more later
let's focus here on what's actually
going on in the text in this little
portion so Hegel sighs essence is split
into two in such a way that two
different ways of considering it are
involved this is not something new this
has been what was sketched out in the
previous paragraphs so he talks about
the negative as one of those and pure
being and this is in fact something
that's not the core of hegelian
metaphysics you see this starting point
in the science of logic you know the
consideration of Being and Nothingness
right are there the negative and so this
is key to what a thing is for Hegel he's
not really going to dwell on that all
that much and here it's it's associated
with particular contents you could say
so he says essence must consider
difference within itself now the
difference is between these two things
it's not as if considering difference is
one of the sides and not considering
difference is the other side there's
already difference
within both sides and there's difference
between both sides so he says because of
this the two ways of considering it
merge into one the abstract moments of
pure being and the negative or in the
previous paragraph thing hood the in
itself and thought consciousness right
of things are united in the object so
considered so these are both aspects of
what is being considered what is that
thing that's being considered ultimately
it's going to be utility but he hasn't
told us that yet so we have to wait
until the end before we're actually
going to see that so Hegel talks here
then about there being a universal
common to both and it's the abstraction
of a pure inward oscillation what's an
oscillation means going back and forth
between these two so there's there's a
kind of dynamic movement there but it's
not a movement that is you know
progressing towards something
oscillation think about a pendulum as it
goes back and forth it swings that's
that's what he's got in mind there and
this pure oscillation is as he says of
pure self thinking that's worth pausing
on for just a moment why well whenever
we're dealing with something that until
we get to the very end that that's self
thinking where the self has become you
might say detached from everything else
out there and it's just considering its
own contents there's more to be
developed the self thinking itself is
never really going to be the end of the
story so that tells us that we're at a
point where something new has to come on
the scene now he calls this a simple
rotatory motion and again oscillation is
going around and around must be
more complex okay why does it have to
become more complex well to begin with
it's not adequate to the reality that
it's been trying to grasp I mean is this
the end point for the Hegelian dialectic
this can't be yet right so we can go on
from here Hegel says why does it have to
be more complex it is itself only motion
by distinguishing its moments and we see
this in Hegel over and over again as a
theme the the the self identical must
repel itself from itself and that is in
part what goes on with negation right
and negation here's another thing we can
say that's not being said explicitly in
the text you never have pure being by
itself there's always the negative
haunting it and that has to be the case
if that pure being is actually going to
be thought because thinking itself goes
beyond the thing thought it's not simply
absorbed in it it's different from it so
he goes on and he says this
distinguishing of the moments leaves
there unmoved unity behind as the empty
husk of pure being which is no longer
actual thought no longer has life within
it this process of differentiation is
quants all the contents so we're no
longer just focusing on the essence as
such we're focusing on what the essence
is unfolding itself into what it's
revealing is going on within it so here
Hegel is going to make an important
transition that's going to lead us into
the the end of this this section now
this is the process which places itself
outside of that unity the process is an
alternation an alternation which does
not return into itself
what is this alternation it's an
alternation of being for another and
being for self so he says it is reality
in the way
this is an object for the actual
consciousness of pure incident this is
what pure insight has been relayed
realizing the real the essential that
which is the most important including
its own self to be utility general
abstract utility utility involves being
for self being conscious of one's own
self right
having that reflexive relation itself
but it also involves being for another
an instrumentality a value insofar as
one leads to one conduces to one brings
about something that matters for another
I am useful for example to you in
hopefully understanding this dense
Hegelian text I have a certain utility
Hegel's text has a certain utility for
us in hopefully expanding our minds to
understand the dialectical process of
history a development of consciousness
you know all of that can be understood
in its being for another and Hegel says
there's an oscillation being for self
being for another that is at the core of
consciousness in the inside of pure
enlightenment
bad as utility
look to faith or sentimentality or even
to the abstract thought that calls
itself speculation which clings to the
in itself yet it is in utility that pure
insight achieves its realization and has
itself for its object an object which it
now no longer repudiates and which to no
longer has for it the value of the void
or the pure beyond for pure insight is
as we saw the existent notion itself or
pure self identical personality
distinguishing itself within itself in
such a way that each of the
distinguished moments is itself pure
notion that is is at the same time not
distinguished pure insight is simple
pure self-consciousness which is for
itself as well as in itself in an
immediate unity it's being in itself is
therefore not an enduring being but in
its difference immediately ceases to be
something such a being however that is
immediately without support is not an
intrinsic being but is essentially for
an other which is the power that absorbs
it but the second moment which is
opposed to the first or the being in
itself equally vanishes immediately like
the first or as a being which is only
for another it is rather the vanishing
itself and there is positive the
accomplish returned into itself being
for self this simple being for self
however is self identity is rather a
mere being or is thereby for another
this nature of pure insight in the
unfolding of its moments or insight qua
object is expressed in the useful what
is useful or is something with with an
enduring being in itself or a thing this
being in itself is at the same time only
a pure moment
hence it is absolutely for another but
equally is for another merely what it is
in itself
these opposed moments have returned into
the indivisible unity of being for self
while the useful does Express the notion
of pure insight it is not pure insight
as such but insight conceived by it in
the form of object it is merely the
Restless alternation
those moments of which it one indeed is
itself the accomplished return into
itself but only as a being for self that
is as an abstract moment appearing on
one side over against the others the
useful itself is not a negative essence
having in itself these moments in their
antithesis and at the same time as
undivided into one in the same respect
or as thought as they are QWOP you're
inside the moment of being for self is
certainly present in the useful but not
in such a way that it over arches the
other moments the in itself and the
being for another in which case it would
be the self pure insight he has
therefore anything useful its own notion
in its pure moments for object it is the
awareness of this metaphysics but not as
yet the comprehension of it
consciousness has not yet reached the
unity of being a notion itself since the
useful still has the form of an object
for pure insight it does have a world
one which it is true is no longer in and
for itself but yet a world which it
distinguishes from itself only since the
antithesis has emerged at the summit of
the notion the next stage will see them
come into collision and the
enlightenment will taste the fruits of
its deeds
paragraph 580 is quite long and there's
a lot going on in this penultimate
portion of this short section the truth
of enlightenment here we are finding out
what the truth of enlightenment actually
is in terms of the useful or utility as
what pure insight grasps itself as and
how it grasps itself in relation to the
world the next paragraph is going to
finish by talking a lot more about that
world so we'll go into that just a
little bit here Hegel begins this
paragraph by saying utility seems bad to
faith or sentimentality notice that
there's a difference here between faith
and sentimentality faith you remember
was the mode of pure thinking it is not
just a feeling some sort of vague
sentiment or something like that instead
faith is an attempt to think out thought
through content and pure insight was
critical of faith and we had this entire
movement of the Enlightenment
sentimentality is something that pops up
over and over and over again and for
Hegel it's always gonna be something
rather debased right so utility looks
bad for sentimentality who cares what
sentimentality Thanks it looks bad for
faith though because it turns everything
into the useful it takes away the
absolute value of its content and that
angle says it also looks bad for
something else
abstract thought that calls itself
speculation now isn't that interesting
we can distinguish between the practical
and the theoretical right and we usually
in philosophy give a higher priority to
the theoretical or if you want to call
it the contemplative or the speculative
or pure reason all right practical well
that's when the realm of ethics and you
know personal choice and maybe politics
and and aesthetics too insofar as it's a
value field and we can have anything
interesting to say and there's usually
this imbalance right let's get the
metaphysics and the epistemology and the
logic down right and then we'll get to
the ethics Hegel never adopt that as a
finished perspective it's not a
effective organizational principle
there's always a back-and-forth going on
between the practical and the
speculative within Hegel the speculative
can only truly be speculative insofar as
it turns into something so in a way the
Enlightenment and pure insight is
leading the theoretical leading faith
belong in its wake like it or not in
terms of the useful in terms of utility
all right so that's the first sentence
right he says it is an utility that pure
insight achieves its realization and has
itself for an object utility is the way
in which pure insight is able to grasp
itself now what is pure insight is pure
insight some kind of you know thing
floating around out there that just
happens to take possession of us every
once in a while like a spirit of the age
no pure insight consists in what it is
that we human beings are doing insofar
as we are self consciously rationally
working from the perspective of pure
insight and not say faith sentimentality
abstract thought or something along
those lines so it's a way in which we
can make sense of ourselves
I am a useful thing I'm also a person
right it allows us to conceptualize
ourselves so he goes on and he says it
has itself for an object an object which
is now no longer repudiates and which to
no longer has for it the value of the
void or the pure beyond the void or the
pure beyond was coming up as absolute
being right now we're centered on purse
and our relations to each other and
fitting into a common social matrix so
he goes on I says pure insight is the
existent notion itself or pure here's a
wonderful phrase pure self identical
personality distinguishing itself within
itself in such a way that each of the
distinguished moments is itself pure
notion we saw that discussed earlier is
at the same time not distinguish pure
insight is simple pure
self-consciousness now here he starts
getting into these distinctions right
which is for itself as well as in itself
in immediate unity now why did I put
being for another and being for self
because in the previous paragraph these
were coming together as as utility so
now the the pure insight conceptualizing
itself is doing so insofar as it grasps
itself both being for another and being
for self but now what is the status of
the being in itself what is it what is
pure insight this is the section truth
of the Enlightenment right so he says
it's being in itself is not an enduring
being as being in itself is not an
enduring being it's in its difference it
ceases to be something so he says such a
being that is immediately without
support is not an intrinsic being but is
essentially for another so the in itself
of the person reveals itself as being
for another should this be a big
surprise to us what is the essence of
self-consciousness it is to exist in
relation to others can you have being in
itself yourself all by yourself before
you come to anybody else
are you even a individual in that
respect no you're an individual insofar
as you exist in relation to others so
Hegel goes on and he says this second
moment which is opposed to the first to
the being in itself
equally vanishes immediately like the
first or as a being that is only for
another now notice the difference there
there's a vast gulf between existing for
another and only existing for another
what is the difference you can exist for
another and also exist in yourself and
also exist exist for yourself the key is
to how to integrate these with each
other right existing only for another
means that you only really have being
value essence insofar as another decides
what you are you become than something
like you know the slave and the
master-slave dialectic at the early
point the uh nacelle consciousness so he
goes on and he says essentially being
essentially for another means being for
the power that absorbs it and he says
this second moment which is opposed to
the first vanishes a being which is only
for another is the vanishing itself
there is positive the accomplished
returned into itself now here's where
Hegel is doing his usual sort of you
know well first we have in a nation and
you know things separating out from each
other and then we have a reintegration
right and I wouldn't worry so much about
what the internal logic is for this
because he doesn't supply it all right
he says the simple being for self as
self identity is a mere being or is for
another so there's a dialectic going on
here between being for self and being
for another what's the upshot of this
what's the payoff
he says the this nature of pure insight
is the unfolding of its moments this
unfolding that we've just done here and
it's expressed in the useful so now he's
going to give us an analysis of the
useful of ourselves as useful things
useful for what we could ask right
and he's gonna answer that so he says
what is useful is something with an
enduring being in itself right it is a
thing
this being in itself he says is at the
same time only a pure moment
hence it is absolutely for another so
these are two aspects right that we've
transpose this now down to here the
useful in order to be useful has to
actually exist at the same time in order
to be useful it has to be useful in
relation to something else so it's being
is is in certain sense dependent right
and he says there we go it's equally for
another merely what it is in itself
these opposed moments have returned into
the indivisible unity of being for self
being for self involves being for
another and having intrinsic being as
he's saying now here's where kids a
little bit more complicated he says the
useful does Express the notion of Puran
so I think the concept that because the
way in which it's understanding itself
in relation to everything else but it's
not pure insight as such but insight
conceived by it in the form of object so
we haven't completely gotten to the
total truth of insight what it is
insight is not completely insightful
about itself you might say so he says we
have this alternation of these moments
one indeed is indeed is for itself the
accomplice returning to itself but only
as being for self only as being for
itself not as being in and for itself
right so he says the useful is not a
negative essence having in itself these
moments in their antithesis or
opposition and at the same time as
undivided and one of the same object the
useful is not a completely developed
concept you might say so he says here we
go
the moment of being for self is present
in the useful but not in such a way that
it over arches the other moments so
you've got this back and forth
everything is involved with everything
else we have the the in itself the being
for another being for itself all present
at the same time and he says purines
Knight has in the useful its own notion
in its pure moments for object not as
subject yet not yet grasping itself
totally for itself and in itself at the
same time now here's where hate Hegel
says something we're quite interesting
it makes a transition that is going to
be important something will dwell upon
in the the last paragraph he brings up
the notion of world so he says it's the
awareness of this metaphysics not yet
comprehension of it awareness is one
thing comprehension means totally
understanding it and comprehending it
would be to have the fully developed
notion the right doesn't have that so he
says the useful still has the form of an
object and it does have a world one
which is no longer in and for itself but
a world which it insight distinguishes
from itself it distinguishes the world
from itself while at the same time being
in the world and using the useful as the
key the way to the lens if you like the
perspective by which to make sense of
the world as a totality of things and of
itself at its own place in that world so
he says since the antithesis have
emerged at the summit of the notion the
concept the next stage is going to see
them come into collision and
enlightenment will taste the fruits of
its deeds now how is it going to taste
those fruits well notice what the next
section is called
absolute freedom hey that sounds like a
good thing right and terror maybe not so
good right so now we just have to get
through the next paragraph and see what
Hegel is going to do with this concept
of world and do a bit of retrospective
of how far we've come before we're ready
to jump into the next section
you